Speaker 1: So there are reports of a massive
shakeup coming to the Fox News primetime lineup
involving Sean HANNITY and Laura Ingraham and
others. Those have not yet been confirmed by Fox
News as of this moment. So let's wait on reporting
those. What I do want to tell you is that the
latest attempt at a Tucker Carlson replacement
since Tucker Carlson was fired, of course,
Fox News has gone through a number of possible
trial hosts. This latest guy is the worst of all
of them so far. So as a reminder, in the immediate
aftermath of the firing of Tucker Carlson, Brian
KILMEADE from Fox and Friends took a shot at it.
Totally milquetoast, just not good. Then Lawrence
Jones came in. Lawrence Jones, notably not ready
for primetime. He tried to come out aggressive,
asking tough questions. He looked visibly confused
about the questions he was asking his guests.
It was a really big cell phone. Then Trump's
former press secretary, Kyle Kayleigh MCENANY,
a completely self-absorbed to a delusional
level, playing videos of herself, speaking at
some former RNC or whatever, really, really bad.
And now Fox News this week tried out Will Cain.
I'm going to show you decoding Fox News, which
is a great Twitter account to follow. Decoding
Fox News made a 92nd summary of a nine
minute monologue that Will Cain did at
the top of last night's show. A misogynistic
rant blaming Jill Biden and Gisele Fetterman,
the wife of Senator John Fetterman, blaming them
for forcing Joe Biden and John Fetterman to take
jobs they can't handle. Attacking Senator Dianne
Feinstein. It's endlessly just that this was the
worst one yet not looking good for Fox News
if this is the best they can come up with it.
Speaker 2: You know, it's so hard to watch.
He's incoherent. And if we're being honest
and not worried about being kind. That was one
of his better moments from yesterday. That man
should not be allowed to operate a power tool
or drive a car, much less govern this country.
Whoa. But as sad as that is for Fetterman,
it's more sad for the people of Pennsylvania.
How did 2.5 million people vote for Fetterman?
Speaker 1: Because the alternative was Dr. Oz.
Speaker 2: What is going on here? Who is using
these people? They're useful idiots. For whom? For
Jill Biden. For just sell. Fetterman. For Chuck
Schumer. We here in the United States of America,
once led by strong men in America, we were led by
visionaries who not only won a revolution against
an empire, but had the humility to limit their own
power through eternal principles enshrined in the
Constitution. Dear God. Titans. Historic titans.
And globally, we were led by men who, between
glasses of brandy and scotch, stared down not
only a tyranny, but also weak weaklings on their
own team in order to win a world war. You know, we
once had Washington and Jefferson and Madison, and
now we have Florida and legislatures doing tick
tock dances on the well of their legislature body.
Now we have Biden, now we have Fetterman. Now we
have Feinstein. And yes, for those individuals,
they are the victims of ambitious spouses, but.
Speaker 1: It's all their spouses that are to be
blamed. So topline could not be less newsworthy,
could not be more of a snooze fest to see. Will
Cain host Tucker Carlson's old show. Here's
one other funny moment. He tried to defend
the actions of suspended NBA player Josh
Morant. And without even looking at notes,
Stephen Smith explains to Will Cain the
totality of what's gone wrong with Morant.
And it will. Cain just has nothing to say.
Speaker 2: See, on the side of your screen,
he's flashing a gun in an Instagram live video.
I said earlier this week, Stephen, that I don't
think he should be suspended for what amounts
to dumb but legal behavior. Everyone, Stephen,
everyone has disagreed with me on this count, and
I know you do as well. Yeah, because, you know,
you usually ill informed when it comes to sports
matters. That's not your forte, even though you
sound great talking about it. But then when we get
to the facts, you always got some slippage there.
Here's the reality of the situation. He's been
involved in several instances. He was involved
in an incident last summer where he allegedly got
into an issue with a high school prospect, came
out of his house with a gun. There was another
issue involving a friend in Indianapolis where
after a game, some kind of laser red dot laser
was being pointed in the direction of some folks
with the Indiana Pacers party. Then there was the
issue. He got suspended over for eight games that
cost him over $600,000. Now, there's this. He
had met with the commissioner, Adam Silver. The
National Basketball Association looked him dead in
his face and essentially told him, this is not me,
this is not indicative of my character, and it
won't happen again. And yet turns around and this
kind of thing happens. So when you're looking
at it in a vacuum and you're thinking about
the fact that no laws were broken, no crime was
committed, and obviously he plays in the state,
I don't know which car where he was in terms of
when he was in the car for the latest incident.
But he plays for the Memphis Grizzlies. That's in
Tennessee and obviously in Tennessee. You don't
even need a permit to carry. So he didn't
break any laws or anything like that. But
the NBA's a private industry and they don't
want to be associated with that because they
remember what it was like in the eighties
when the show when the league was on tape.
Speaker 1: The late Will Cain desperate to try to
make some point, but he just knows nothing about
this. And Stephen Smith completely schooling
him. So, bottom line, not ready for prime
time. Another failed attempt at replacing Tucker
Carlson, who's relaunching his show on Twitter.
I guess very soon it will be very interesting to
see what becomes of the new Fox News lineup. But
I don't think Will Cain is going to be the steward
of that new primetime lineup and ratings not good.